[Music]
the weekend is opening up about his 2018
ep
my dear melancholy which fans think
references his past
relationships with bella hadid and
selena gomez
although he didn't go into specific
details about the meaning behind the
project
he did tell esquire magazine why it was
so important for him to write and
release the record the reason why it was
so
short is like i think i just had nothing
else to say on this
it was just like this cathartic piece of
art and yeah it was sure
because that's all i had to say on this
situation
despite not speaking directly about the
lyrics on my dear melancholy
the weeknd did address some past lyrics
which have been perceived as
misogynistic
so during his candid interview one
specific line from his hit
2015 song the hills was mentioned and
when asked whether the words defined him
as a person
he said that it's definitely a character
it's like you want people to feel a
certain way
you want them to feel angry you want
them to feel sad you want them to
feel it's never like my intent to offend
anybody i'm a writer
sometimes i write a song and it's not in
my head i'm writing it for someone else
but then
i end up singing it the grammy award
winner also revealed that he plans to
write a full
album for female artists telling esquire
i want to write a whole album for female
artists
i have a whole vision of the weekend but
i guess it's like
it's the same reason why i want to write
for someone else
you